a salsa bar in a taco time in dolls
Oregon is the site of the largest
bioterrorist attack in US history and no
this is not a joke in 1970 in India a
spiritual leader named Bhagwan Shree
Rajneesh began a new movement the
philosophy of the Raj nashi movement was
an odd mix of capitalism meditation and
dirty and ethnic jokes nonetheless he
managed to accumulate a large following
by the 1980s his movement had swelled to
the tens of thousands Rajneesh wanted to
start his utopia so with the help of
this woman ma Anan Sheila they purchased
64,000 acres a ranch in Oregon and it
was here that they began building their
utopia some 7,000 followers moved onto
this ranch property the followers all
wore red they adhered to very strict
schedules meanwhile Manon Sheila began
calling herself Queen and carrying
around a 357 magnum the Raja she's also
began driving around town in a jeep with
a machine gun on the back of it the plan
was to overwhelm these towns by
basically taking over their political
systems the Raja she's had already taken
over a nearby town called Antelope and
renamed the town Rajesh the huge influx
of these red clad cultists didn't sit
that well with the local conservative
small town errs in Oregon the Raj
national movement needed ways to inflate
their numbers and essentially keep the
locals away from the voting polls what
if everyone was too sick to actually go
out and vote in September of 1984 a
woman stood at the salsa bar on Taco
Time holding a small bag of her own
homemade salsa she poured it across all
of the condiments and this started what
was the largest bioterrorist attack in
US history the group contaminated ten
different fast food restaurants with
salmonella
over the course of two months it made
757 people sick
it sent a couple dozen people to the
hospital had they gone with their
initial plan of using typhoid fever it
would have been a massacre when this
finally was discovered it was found that
they had set up a fully fledged
bioterrorism lab on the compound my nan
Sheila and her co-conspirators were
given twenty years in prison but
ultimately only ended up serving two and
Rajesh actually didn't serve a day in
jail the attack on the salsa bar at the
Taco Time and nine other fast-food
restaurants remains the largest bio
terrorist attack in US history amazingly
that taco time is still open we suggest
you skip the salsa bar subscribe here
and watch more videos here today there's
still a plaque in the town antelope it's
awesome actually it's at the post office
and it's like something out of a movie
like like to all those who stood against
the Raj neti invasion what are some
other wonders that I should know about
what do you want to hear me talk about
what do you want to tell me about what
is the greatest place you've ever been I
want to know all these things